there is a fight literally a verbal
fight happening right now
to be Donald Trump's vice presidential
running mate in 2024. on the one hand
you have radical and repugnant
Republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green she's desperate to be Trump's VP I
told you about that last week on the
other hand you have loser Kerry Lake who
simply cannot accept more people voted
for your opponent and you lost and it's
over
they are now engaged in a battle to be
Donald Trump's vice presidential running
mate let's start with Carrie Lake who at
the very same event over the weekend
during which we already played One Clip
she said the fight is not over over the
Arizona gubernatorial race here's a
secret it's over it's over you've lost
she spent two minutes just sucking up to
Trump at that very same event making it
abundantly clear she is campaigning to
be Trump's VP listen to this groveling
my second favorite guy stood up on the
stage right up there in beautiful
Mar-A-Lago and said he's going to run
for office again and I am so excited
about it who's excited about that
there he is
and I will tell you this right now I
don't know what my future holds other
than I'm going to continue to fight for
this country but I will do everything in
my power to make sure this man gets back
in the white house we need him now more
than ever
there's no other option there's nobody
better for the job there's nobody who
could get us out of this nightmare that
we're in then somebody who introduced
America First policies can you believe
so I ask you in the coming days and
months and weeks as we're hearing you
know the fake news media talk that we
stand up and protect and push and and do
everything we can to help president
Trump in his move toward the White House
I will do anything in my power to make
sure this man gets in the white house
for our children's sake and for our
country's sake are you guys with us on
that
foreign
a lot of campaigning for the guy who
claims he doesn't need anybody's help
really with us
[Applause]
the boat most beautiful place I've ever
been Mar-A-Lago and I'm thrilled to be
here with people who are fighting for
America more like the gaudiest place
she's ever been my first policy is the
only way we get out of this mess is the
America First policies that President
Trump introduced and we need strong
States and strong Governors and strong
leaders from the President right on down
to the school board member let me
rephrase that we need strong leaders
from the school board right on up to the
president most importantly the school
board so thank you so much for being
here tonight thank you president Trump
for inspiring all of us and Mr President
and we are with you we've got your back
and we will be with you right until we
get you back in the White House
all right so that is a please pick me to
be your VP sort of speech and then as a
reminder here's Marjorie Taylor green
she's desperate to be Trump's pick for
2024 and she's concerned that DeSantis
and this was before Carrie Lake Lost
Lake really serve a long time as
Governors and not abandon anybody
because if they did it might mean
Marjorie doesn't get to be Trump's VP
listen to this chlorine and tries to
challenge president Trump as far as
being the Republican nominee for 2024 we
feel like it's political suicide this is
his party this is his race to run do you
want to share your thoughts on that
absolutely I I think that it's clear and
obvious president Trump is the People's
Choice he's the one that we elected in
2016. we re-elected him in 2020 and we
will elect him in 2024. what we need in
this country Brian is we need strong
Republican Governors like Ron DeSantis
we need strong Republican Governors we
need Kerry Lake to win in Arizona we
need strong Republican Governors to
fight stay in for eight years and save
their states eight years just long
enough that they wouldn't be able to
either run for president if you're
talking about DeSantis or be Trump's VP
if you're talking about Kerry Lake not
to abandon their states and try to run
for president or any other big position
could she be any more obvious in what
she's trying to do the last thing we
need I mean for the party right for the
movement but for the movement the best
thing would be DeSantis should be
Governor multiple more times Kerry Lake
should be governor for close to a decade
they should not try to run for president
she's campaigning for herself as VP only
a trump supporter would see primary
Trump as an act of betrayal and this is
going to be extraordinary once it gets
going let me know what you think make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube at
youtube.com slash the David packman show
much more coming up today
as many of you know I am fascinated by
cons and scams and multi-level marketing
and all of this different stuff I
recently saw Inside the Mind of a con
artist on curiosity stream it's six
episodes and it was excellent I don't
think I would have discovered it were it
not for our sponsor curiosity stream
curiosity stream has all the newest and
best documentary films they've got the
big titles from the well-known
filmmakers they've got valuable
Independent films tons of original
content that you can't find anywhere
else when I'm at home browsing my
different streaming platforms I find
curiosity stream to really have the best
selection of documentaries specifically
because documentaries is all that they
have and they're always adding new
titles my audience gets access to
curiosity streams entire library of
documentaries for just 15 bucks a year
that's 25 off go to to
curiositystream.com Pacman or use the
code Pacman the link is down below